What the hell is that?
The--what? No, nothing.
It's nothing. I'm nothing.
You need to work on
your self-esteem, you idiot.
It looks like a letter to me.
I got a letter once.
From an old lover telling me
she contracted
the Sailor's Virus.
- I hate letters.
- Oh, please tell us.
It's a letter from
the Triangle Shirtwaist factory.
They offered me a job interview
for tomorrow.
It's always been my dream
to work in a factory.
To feel the steam on my face
and the hot crush of machinery
against my finger pads.
[laughs]
Factory life!
No, thanks.
Well, I hope everyone's
happily lazing about savoring
the delights of all meal.
Thanks to your indolence,
the urine buckets under the sink
have become filled
to the point of over slosh.
Why hasn't this been taken
care of?
I believe that was
Garfield's job, sir.
And you sacked him
for stealing a towel, sir.
So, it wasn't indolence, sir.
It was a staffing issue, sir.
Call me sir one more time,
I shall dock your gruel
for a week.
What would you like me
to call you?
Sir will do.
Just pace it out.
Hamish,
you will empty the urine.
Sorry, Peeps,
according to my contract,
I don't touch piss, mops,
or Gypsies.
Oh, very well.
I shall empty it myself.
I'm so excited for you!
Factory life!
[both laugh]
[laughs]
[rap music]